The joe rogan experience.
So,
um,
yeah,
so mma,
who named it mixed martial arts.
You know what?
That's it.
Look it.
That's a whole story.
And you're going to hear,
I heard it was you.
Well,
I,
I give credit to Jeff Blatnick as far as
looking at,
ah,
he didn't come up with the term who did,
but the truth,
and this is the first thing I can tell
you,
I wrote,
I wrote a,
uh,
I had to do it what's called a work
permit for lapd because I worked for
lapd back in 1993,
93,
[inaudible] 94.
And it was because I was going to
referee the second UFC,
which was March 11th,
in 1994.
And for me to actually work,
the department has to allow me to,
I have to ask for permission and then
they have to grant that permission.
Was there a concern that it was too
outrageous?
So that was part of the whole thing is I
didn't want to say,
oh,
I got two guys going into a cage.
They're going to beat the shit out of
each other.
So the first thing I put was a martial
arts referee.
Hmm,
okay.
And then they said,
well,
what kind of martial arts?
So I wrote mixed martial arts referee.
Now I can tell you that that was in 90
right at the end of [inaudible] 93 a
term.
I didn't get it from anywhere other than
I'm sitting there trying to think of,
but I do know that there was a
columnist,
a sports writer from the La Times that
wrote about the very first UFC,
and in his article wrote mixed martial
arts.
Ah,
so maybe it was him.
So,
well,
you've got John Perretti saying that
he's,
you know,
he did it back in 1983 it's like,
okay,
well if no one's saying it,
it doesn't mean shit.
Right.
Okay.
So the truth of the matter is,
so peretti might have said it in
[inaudible] 83 he might've said it,
but it didn't mean anything because the
fact of the matter is,
and it doesn't matter what I wrote,
what matters is when,
you know,
when you joined it,
when you joined the UFC,
it was still considered no holds barred.
NHB.
Yeah,
he was what we called and it was
something that was,
and this is,
you know,
probably part of my problem with
Campbell Mclaren is back at you before
ufc too,
you know,
good.
They had them on Good Morning America
with Jim Brown and you go back to that
and he came up with the line that you
could win by knockout,
tap out or death.
Okay.
And four years after that,
I was in court having that thrown in my
face by the fricking attorneys trying to
put us down saying,
isn't this what your company's,
no,
that's not what my cock fighting.
That's what an idiot said.
Okay.
And so he still to this day thinks he
was magnificent with that.
Maybe,
you know,
it was kind of a shamanic ceremony.
Maybe it wouldn't be a problem at all.
Here's the deal.
It's all one thing getting fucked up.
Shamonic whatever.
If you taking drugs and you fucked up,
you fucked up.
It doesn't matter if it's shamonic or
not.
If you,
if you get high and,
and that and the tweaks,
that little thing in my brain that goes
here,
I go,
remember in your brain,
I got high for 30 years,
right.
I'm from the 60s with the best of them.
I got high and it took them down.
Some of them,
most of them.
You came through it remarkably unscathed
if you think about it.
Yeah.
Thank you God.
It's pretty amazing.
Think about that one.
Yeah.
Think about that.
We could talk for two hours about times
I did shit and almost died.
So sure.
You know,
and then I could also tell you,
um,
how many times I took shit and wrote
things like,
you know,
I'm listening to this guitar lick that
Joe's playing.
He did an interview here with you,
but he didn't tell you how it is.
Fucking sleepy would play these rifts.
And I come down the hallway because as I
see it,
of course not as ac it,
but as I see it,
we were up in New England and he was
playing at a place and I mowed the lawn,
my,
my parents place.
And I quit my last band and I was
fucking a Lou who saw her.
I was crying,
I was no more bands.
The dream was over.
He drives up in an mg,
we go and he's playing that night.
I swear to God this happened.
And so we decided to move down to
Boston,
but all in an apartment because I
thought I knew why those bands didn't
make it.
But I knew in my heart did,
if I had a borrowed a band,
like a mic and a keith,
like the kinks,
David,
Dave,
and you know,
ray,
any of those bands they have,
they have,
you know,
have,
it was two guys that were really tight.
They feed off each other.
The Fed off each other.
Exactly.
So we moved down there.
I got really tight with Joe [inaudible].
I hear him.
He'd get,
we'd get so swept.
We were so stoned on booze,
boone's farm,
you know when we fucking her,
I said,
what'd you say?
What'd you say?
Anyway,
but he would play these licks.
It was so fucking for every song you've
ever heard.
Sweet emotion.
Every one of those lex walk this way.
There's 20 that got lost in the ether,
right?
20th ago.
Lawson ether.
So I went out and bought a little thing
called the tape recorder back then.
Remember this was 71 you know it's a lot
of shit.
Wasn't no phones,
no cell phones.
So I would record that shit.
And so anyway,
what were we going with this?
That's,
that's what,
that's what these songs came from and
stuff would come out of my head while I
was like sweet [inaudible] low tion
wait,
Whoa,
fuck,
get me paid paper and pen.
I write that shit down suddenly.
Whoops.
On the radio.
So I use that place you get,
you go to,
when you eat edibles,
do you have a ride?
So many routines when you in animals.
Well there you go.
Yeah,
no,
for sure.
Well and also check this out.
The best part of it is when I got sober,
I started right.
Even even better shit.
I go in a room with four guys and say
we're going into right ahead.
We're going to say in his fucking room
until we do or until we can't stand each
other smell.
And we would leave in seven hours with a
fucking song and a good one and one that
would live way past all of us.
Check that shit out.
But that's a lot of damage.
What can be done is the ideas can die.
The ideas of,
of fascism,
the ideas of racism,
the,
those,
those things we can kill.
Right.
Um,
but are those ideas,
are those ideas being fostered and these
in these communities?
Yes.
Yeah.
They're being cultivated.
Cause it's like you experienced it.
Yeah.
I mean if I'm a white guy,
white guy walking down the street,
I am,
I am a higher degree than the locals.
You know,
like I can,
I can go and shop in some places that
they can't.
I can go in and sit down and,
and have a meal in some places that they
can't.
I cannot be greeted on the street and
good Morgan,
you know,
um,
not,
not the brown dude next to me.
He's not.
And His kid definitely can't date the
blue eyed blonde girl at the high
school.
That's not allowed.
So they basically created these little
colonies.
Yeah.
Yahtzee colonies in South America.
Did you Google Google cloney digging?
Yeah.
Did you,
you will have nightmares.
She did.
I'm freaking out right now.
It's years.
It's crazy how many people got away with
it that Joseph Mengele died on a beach.
That's [inaudible] wife.
I mean that,
that,
that would hurts me cause he's a guy
like me just on the ops cause he,
and he's a special operations guy.
He was an ss.
Um,
he's,
he was,
he was a physical specimen,
especially for the time,
you know,
like we didn't understand.
I mean he was,
uh,
he was a very early on into the,
one of the first real Nazis.
Like this isn't okay.
All of Germany's going this way.
The chancellor is Adolf Hitler.
This is where we're going.
I kind of just have to go along and you
see some of that in the third and
they're like 43,
44.
Um,
now it's okay.
We might be losing this war.
Now it's not so in vogue,
but when you got guys in like 1939 that
are talking eugenics and um,
you know,
higher calling for breeding and
segregation,
um,
early on you're like,
Eh,
I don't like that guy.
Kona beat him to death with my hands,
but he's massive.
So it'd be a pretty good fight.
Yeah,
it was a,
there we go.
A form Nazi cult trying to,
what does it say?
Jamie was the full,
uh,
title Nazi Colt.
What does the uh,
so that,
that,
that's just a marketing thing because
it's still the same place.
Reformed Nazi cult trying to open it's
colony to,
and where's this?
That's in Chile.
Yeah.
I spent a lot of time there right there.
Oh,
they made a movie about it.
So that's current day right there.
Jesus Christ.
That later hoses range is freaking
gorgeous though.
It's,
I mean it is Shangri la.
Yeah.
German flag flying.
Wow.
They've tried to hide the Nazi things
they've had.
I met some people that I'm like,
I talked to him.
I go,
oh,
I'm like a monkey
dude.
I talked to your Buddy Eddie Bravo.
And that guy is a real,
he's out there.
He's like a jack.
He's like a death,
like a death Jack Russell almost,
you know,
a deaf Jack Russell because once he gets
going,
you can't,
oh,
Jack Russell terrier.
You ever been around with his dog?
He opened the car and then the next
thing you know,
they're like,
oh yeah,
they're like sick.
Yeah,
but well,
how's he depth?
Cause you can't get him back.
Like once he goes,
you can't,
I was saying,
you can't get them back in the car.
Like you're sitting there honking the
horn.
You can't,
that guy's out there.
You know my home.
You know what I'm talking about.
But I've never already might make a
description like that.
Jack Russell terrier.
That is hilarious.
Extravagant dude.
Yeah.
That means extravagant,
so motivated.
He loves conspiracies more than anybody
I've ever met in my life.
And he thinks everything is a
conspiracy.
Yeah,
no,
he definitely,
yeah,
but then he gets into it like,
I dunno,
it was fascinating to me how he went
from this like one John Rowe of life to
the next and created a business in each
one and kept moving forward.
A business.
Yeah.
He got like,
he was a music.
He liked music.
He started a band,
you know,
he liked karate.
He started doing,
um,
you know,
organized karate.
He liked,
uh,
you know,
what else did he pee?
A couple of other businesses.
I think he got a new,
a couple of other things.
I don't know what the other two,
he lost me a chapter 70.
But he'll hit you with too much
information,
man.
It was crazy.
A lot of people to Google.
I was like,
I want to climb through a black hole
right now.
Casey reason shit.
Like,
wait a minute.
It's just kind of the jet dude the other
night,
2:00 AM he sends me a couple of legs.
You gotta shut your phone off.